machtkampf in sachsen-anhalt eskaliert
cdu ministerpräsident reiner haseloff
entlässt innenminister holger
stahlknecht strategie gegen korona
hotspots gesundheitsminister sparen
fordert schärfere regeln in besonders
betroffenen regionen schnelltest in
österreich millionen bürger werden
freiwillig auf das virus getestet um so
eine weitere ausbreitung zu verhindern
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
heute am freitag einem brisanten
nachrichten tag den sport gibt es in
eine viertelstunde von und mit norbert
lehmann den ball am tor von mir
der streit über den rundfunkbeitrag
brachte es zu tage durch die cdu in
sachsen anhalt geht ein tieferes denn
ein teil der partei will gegen eine
erhöhung um 86 cent stimmen ebenso wie
die afg heute zurück ministerpräsident
haseloff die reißleine und entließ cdu
innenminister holger stahlknecht grund
ein nicht abgestimmtes interview zur
koalitionskrise das ende für ein ohnehin
lädiertes vertrauensverhältnis seit 2011
hatten sie zusammen regiert haseloff als
ministerpräsident stahlknecht als
innenminister und aktueller
cdu-landeschef nun der bruch weil
stahlknecht in dem zeitungsinterview das
ende der schwarz rot grünen koalition
und eine mögliche minderheitsregierung
der cdu in den raum gestellt hatte noch
während man sich um eine lösung für den
streit um den rundfunkbeitrag bemühte
zunächst aus magdeburg hagen nicolas mit
einem interview stellt sachsen anhalts
innenminister und cdu landeschef volker
steuert nicht die machtfrage in der
koalition und in der eigenen cdu
fraktion
der streit um die haltung sachsen
anhalts zum neuen medien staatsvertrag
und die erhöhung des rundfunkbeitrages
jetzt droht der cdu landeschef mit der
schwarz rot grünen koalition für den
fall dass spd und grüne bei ihrer
zustimmung bleiben stallknecht bringt
dem interview auch eine tolerierung
durch die afd ins spiel
dann käme es zu einer
minderheitsregierung und zur regulären
landtagswahl am 6 juni 2021 so stark
nicht im interview
damit stellt er sich gegen
ministerpräsident haselhoff der anders
als seine cdu-fraktion einer abstimmung
zum medien staatsvertrag im landtag
verhindern wollte um so die kinder
koalition zu retten
mit der entlassung seines innenministers
zieht ministerpräsident haselhoff nun
die notbremse
dieser habe unabgestimmt und öffentlich
den koalitionsbruch und die möglichkeit
einer allein von der cdu gebildeten
minderheitsregierung in den raum
gestellt heißt es in der einzigen
presseerklärung dazu grüne und spd
begrüßen die entlassung des
innenministers halten sie aber für
unzureichend streit nicht weiter cdu
landesvorsitzender der konflikt den
diese koalition jetzt auszuhalten hat
ist damit nicht ausgeräumt wir stehen
immer noch vor der situation dass wir
unterschiedliche fraktionen in der cdu
haben und dass sich jetzt entscheiden
muss ob die rechtsgerichteten kräfte die
fdp fraktion in der cdu die macht
ergreift oder ob es die gemäßigten
kräfte tun auf jeden fall ist jetzt die
chance tatsächlich wiedergegeben
miteinander zu reden und auch eine
lösung zu suchen und möglicherweise auch
zu finden
übersteigt nicht hat mit seinem
interview der volksstimme all diese
türen zugeschlagen und die sind jetzt
wieder offen und ich gehe davon aus dass
wir bis nächste woche auch weiterhin
gespräche miteinander führen werden
in sachsen anhalt steht die union vor
der zerreißprobe
wer sich am ende durchsetzen kann ist
offen ja da bleiben fragen an unsere
korrespondenten zunächst andreas weise
in sachsen-anhalt andreas im interview
kündigt stahlknecht ja indirekt eine art
coach an
deswegen seine entlassung heute wie geht
es denn jetzt in cdu und koalition
weiter
zuallererst muss einmal geklärt werden
wie es im beitrag eben auch schon
anklang wer denn jetzt eigentlich die
macht in der partei landes partei und in
der fraktion hat es ist so dass
ministerpräsident haseloff zwar in der
bevölkerung sehr beliebt ist vor allem
auch durch seine art wie er die korona
krise hier in sachsen anhalt manager
aber er hat in der partei und vor
einigen der fraktion nicht besonders
viel rückhalt
jetzt geht es darum bleibt aber stark
nicht trotzdem landesparteichef da ist
also noch eine menge zu klären das
dürfte am wochenende noch relativ
spannend werden ja und dann ist nächste
woche die nächste frage zu klären
nämlich kann die kenia koalition halten
immer noch sind die meinungen zum medien
staatsvertrag sehr unterschiedlich das
zusammen zu bekommen scheint sehr sehr
schwer zu werden
einer der steine meilensteine auf diesem
weg könnte nächste woche mittwoch wieder
der sogenannte medienausschuss des
landtages und magdeburg sein und dann
werden wir weiter sehen eventuell ist
die kieler koalition schon in der
kommenden woche am ende
vielen dank andreas weise in magdeburg
und damit gleich zu gunther love energy
in berlin und anna und was bedeutet das
alles nun für die bundes cdu hätte die
parteispitze nicht längst eingreifen
müssen
die frage ist ob das geholfen hätte denn
für die cdu geht es insgesamt um die
frage wie sie mit der afg umgeht die
partei hat man mehrheitlich einen
beschluss gefasst dass sie mit der afg
nicht kooperiert und von teilen der cdu
im osten wird es immer wieder in frage
gestellt beim letzten mal als sich die
parteivorsitzende da einmischen wollte
in thüringen bei der wahl zum
ministerpräsidenten
da hat es annegret kramp karrenbauer den
job gekostet und die spannende frage
wird jetzt sein wie positionieren sich
ihre möglichen nachfolger denn wir sehen
an diesem ereignis das thema schwelt
weiter und wer auch immer den
bundesvorsitz übernehmen wird wird
dieses problem auch erben
vielen dank jahrhundert manager zum
stand der korona pandemie in deutschland
fünf wochen nach beginn des teil
shutdowns lässt die erhoffte trendumkehr
auf sich warten
23 1449 neuinfektionen meldet das robert
koch institut heute das sind 600 43 mehr
als vor einer woche
432 weitere männer
sind an oder mit dem virus gestorben
und so wird diskutiert ob wir in
regionen mit besonders hohen
infektionszahlen noch schärfere regeln
erlassen werden sollten
pablo sie la la he fast zusammen
mannheim in baden württemberg mit einem
incidents wert von über 200
neuinfektionen pro 100.000 einwohnern
einer der hotspots des landes noch sind
die menschen auch in den abendstunden
unterwegs ab heute nacht herrscht hier
von 21 uhr bis 5 uhr morgens eine
ausgangssperre
wie sie auch andere städte des landes
planen schön ist es natürlich nicht ich
weiß auch nicht so wirklich etwas
bewirkt oder wenn da nennt man es vorher
machen müssen und nicht denn wenn ich
kacke am dampfen das sagt man so schön
weil dadurch das dann ausgangs
beschränkungen sind kann man sich auch
nicht so lange bei freunden drin treffen
und dadurch kommen auch nicht so viele
leute denken ich zusammen
auch andere bundesländer planen
nächtliche ausgangssperren für ihre
hotspots ausdrückliche unterstützung für
schärfere maßnahmen kommt vom
bundesgesundheitsminister da wo es hohe
infektionszahlen gibt in deutschland
braucht es aus meiner sicht unbedingt
zusätzliche über das was vereinbart
wurde
zusätzliche einschränkende maßnahmen zur
kontakt reduzierung zustimmung auch von
biologen mit einer ausgangssperre habe
ich natürlich die möglichkeit viel viel
besser eben den verkehr draußen zu
kontrollieren und damit zu vermeiden
dass sich menschen privat treffen
das hessische offenbach ist mit einem
incidents wert von gut 316 einer der
spitzenreiter bundesweit schärfere
maßnahmen sind hier aber dennoch nicht
geplant
vergleiche mit anderen städten so das
gesundheitsamt seien wenig hilfreich
die zahlen enttäuschen da auch ein
bisschen weil sie haben wir hier eine
reine großstadt während wenn sie die
anderen kreise sich angucken da haben
sie immer bestimmte verdünnungseffekt
durch zum beispiel den den landkreis
durch die große landbevölkerung eine
einheitliche lösung wird es ohnehin
nicht geben über maßnahmen wie eine
nächtliche ausgangssperre
können die kommunen eigenständig
entscheiden
trotz der verzögerungen bei der
auslieferung des corona impfstoffs von
montech und seinem us-partner pfizer
bleibt gesundheitsminister sparen
zuversichtlich er gehe davon aus dass es
zum jahreswechsel erste impfungen in
deutschland geben können
als gründe für die schwierigkeiten
endphase probleme unter anderem beim
ausbau der lieferketten für das kommende
jahr aber will das unternehmen wie
geplant mehr als eine milliarde
impfdosen bereitstehen
ein teststäbchen in die nase oder in den
rachen wenig später hat man das ergebnis
so funktioniert der korona schnelltests
neuerdings auch zugelassen für den
eigengebrauch in schulen oder kitas
klingt ganz einfach hat aber tücken
ärzte fürchten falsche ergebnisse wenn
der abstrich nicht korrekt erfolgt und
manche schule fühlt sich überfordert
elisabeth schmidt berichtet seit heute
ist die neue bundesweite corona test
strategie in kraft daran den meisten
schulen in deutschland sieht es so aus
wie an der leonore goldschmidt schule in
hannover
die schnelltests für lehrkräfte gibt es
schlicht noch nicht ich habe das gestern
auch aus der presse erfahren
und heute morgen in der zeitung gelesen
wenn das über den schulträger
angeschafft wird wird man sehen wie
lange das dauert erzieher/innen und
schulen und kitas dürfen die
schnelltests jetzt auch selber
durchführen nach vorheriger anleitungen
schüler in dann sollen vorerst nicht
getestet werden wann es los geht und
werde die testverlierer kräfte am ende
bezahlt ist noch unklar
wir würden uns natürlich erwarten dass
personalmaßnahme und das ist ja eine
wichtige maßnahme schnelltests an
schulen um zum beispiel quarantäne
zeiten zu verringern hat dass sich der
bund und ländern abstimmen aber das
scheint nicht geschehen zu sein
von einem schnellschuss und kuddel
muddel ist die rede
der bundesgesundheitsminister hält
dagegen es ist ja jetzt auch keine
verpflichtung sondern eine zusätzliches
angebot eine zusätzliche möglichkeit zu
dem sich die schulen die schulträger die
gesundheitsämter die behörden vor ort
entscheiden können und es gibt mir
zusätzliche sicherheit einfach für die
lehrerinnen und lehrer
bislang wurden dem robert-koch-institut
636 corona ausbrüche in schulen
übermittelt den vergangenen vier wochen
60 ausbrüche pro woche tendenz steigend
ärzte warnen dennoch vor schnelltest
durch medizinische laien mein erster
gedanke war anschließend haben wir
lauter falsche negativer tests und die
menschen wiegen sich in der trügerischen
sicherheit und her da haben wir mehr
infiziert als vorher
vor weihnachten wird es an den meisten
schulen aber wohl noch keine
schnelltests geben weiter also wie
bislang auch in hannover weiter die
hygieneregeln beachten
in zdf heute live sprechen wir mit einer
mikrobiologin darüber wie sinnvoll und
zuverlässig die schnelltests sind auch
sie können fragen stellen um halb acht
auf zdf heute.de und in unserer app auch
österreich setzt jetzt auf freiwillige
schnelltest aber flächendeckende das
ziel der regierung infizierte ohne
symptome entdecken und infektionsketten
unterbrechen
bisher sind trotz eines weitreichenden
lockt downs die zahl der neuansteckungen
eher langsam und der vergleich mit
deutschland zeigt die sieben tages
inzidenz liegt mit über 270 auf 100000
einwohner etwa doppelt so hoch wie bei
uns cornelia donath über den staat der
massen tests der ablauf ist genau
geregelt am eingang gibt es eine ffp
zwei maske um zu verhindern dass der
massentest zum superstar der event wird
und nur wer sich online einen termin
geholt hat da freien sowie wien in
seinen drei größten hallen pro tag bis
zu 150.000 personen schnell testen und
positive befunde direkt mit einem
pcr-test absichern
bisher waren es 58 die maßen testungen
haben jetzt den ziehen dass wir vor
allem menschen zusätzlich identifizieren
können erkennen können partie derzeit
keine symptome haben die entweder presse
tomatis oder auch symptomatisch sind
neben wien starteten heute auch
vorarlberg und tirol mit den massen
tests in innsbruck kamen bis zum
nachmittag rund 12.000 in die messehalle
29 von ihnen waren positiv die regierung
hofft dass sich knapp zwei drittel der
österreicher testen lassen um genügend
infektionsketten durchbrechen zu können
bislang haben die hallen im land in den
nächsten tagen noch viele termine frei
denn es gibt auch skepsis
solange ich mich an die regeln halte
denke ich nicht dass es das ist
notwendig werde das ist der twingo und
mich da testen lassen
also ich lasse mich nicht testen
geschlossen weil ich gesund bin
kritiker bemängeln außerdem dass die
massentests nur eine momentaufnahme und
zielgenau tests aussagekräftiger sein
ja also es stimmt das ist eine
momentaufnahme so man findet nur die
leute heraus die genau heute oder zu dem
zeitpunkt der abnahme tatsächlich stark
positiv waren
das muss auch solche kommuniziert werden
an die leute um sie nicht in falsche
sicherheit zu hören die regierung kurz
plant daher die massentests anfang
januar zu wiederholen
der us kongress will den von
us-präsident trump geplanten truppen
auszug aus deutschland vorerst
blockieren
so steht es in einem gemeinsamen
gesetzentwurf von republikanern und
demokraten im sommer hatte trump
angekündigt etwa 12.000 amerikanische
soldatinnen und soldaten aus deutschland
abzuziehen und dies mit einem zu
geringen deutschen nato beitrag
begründet deal oder no deal das ist die
frage in den bric cit verhandlungen
knapp vier wochen vor ablauf der
übergangsfrist spitzt sich die lage
zwischen der eu und großbritannien
offenbar dramatisch zu noch am
wochenende soll eine entscheidung fallen
eu chefunterhändler bahn je führte heute
intensive gespräche mit der britischen
seite in london ein wichtiger tag rief
er den reportern zu ja da fragen wir
diana zimmermann in london von den brics
in verhandlungen hieß es ja schon öfter
sie seien auf der zielgeraden jetzt
scheint es wohl wirklich ernst zu werden
oder diana es muss jetzt denn schon
jetzt ist kaum mehr zeit diesen vertrag
noch zu ratifizieren die ganze woche
wird hier in dem gebäude hinter mir
schon verhandelt mit shell barren je
will jetzt auch übers wochenende bleiben
beide seiten sagen sie wollen alles
geben damit der deal übers wochenende
zustande kommt allerdings wollen sie
natürlich auch dabei gesehen werden wie
sie bis zur letzten sekunde für die
interessen ihrer bürger kämpfen
und deswegen haben wir auch die schon
bekannten warnungen gehört man sei
keineswegs unter
den umständen zu kompromissen bereit
sollte es jetzt doch zu diesem deal
kommen dann wird das ein sehr dünner
deal seien ein wirklich harter dragset
aber immer noch besser als der no deal
braig cit mit dem immer wieder gedroht
wird
in beiden fällen kommt es zu einer
deutlichen verschlechterung des handels
zwischen großbritannien und der eu der
handel wird sehr viel mehr hürden nehmen
müssen
sollte es aber wirklich einen deal geben
dann wäre das vor allen dingen für
großbritannien das von corona stark
getroffen ist eine wirtschaftliche
katastrophe und für beide seiten eine
politische bankrotterklärung london und
brüssel haben sehr viel kapital und sehr
viel zeit und energie in die
verhandlungen gesteckt scheitern sie
jetzt so würde das ein trauriges signal
aussenden
außerdem würden daraufhin mit
sicherheits schuldzuweisungen von beiden
seiten folgen und das würde das klima
zwischen großbritannien und der eu nur
noch weiter vergiften
die einschätzung von diana zimmermann
vielen dank dafür nach london
der thüringer landtag hat die
abgeordneten immunität von
ministerpräsident ramelow aufgehoben
das ermöglicht ermittlungen der
staatsanwaltschaft es geht um
beleidigung
ramelow hatte im land im landtag einem
abgeordneten der afg den mittelfinger
gezeigt und ihn einen so wörtlich
widerlichen drecksack genannt der linken
politiker hat sich später dafür
entschuldigt
nach dem flughafen jetzt die kanzler
linie in berlin ist ein weiteres
wichtiges verkehrsprojekt eröffnet
worden
die u-bahn-linie u5 führt jetzt
durchgehend durch das zentrum der
hauptstadt
die lücke zwischen dem brandenburger tor
und dem alexanderplatz wurde damit
geschlossen gut zwei kilometer lang
drei weitere stationen schon helmut kohl
hatte sich für die strecke stark gemacht
daher der name kanzler linie ja und nun
zum sport und zur norbert und zur
fußball-europa-league ja und da hat
hoffenheim gestern abend den einzug in
die zwischenrunde geschafft durch das
null zu null gegen roter stern belgrad
und auch leverkusen ist weiter in einem
deutlich torreichen spiel besiegte bayer
netzer mit 3 zu 2
das team von peter busch hat gerade mit
dem tore schießen wenig mühe 17 treffer
in fünf gruppenspielen in der euroleague
in nizza bringen muss er die abi und
aleksander dragovic die leverkusener
zweimal in führung
unnötige gegentreffer führen jeweils zum
ausgleich ein patzer von radetzky
verhilft inter zum 22 kurz nach der
pause
wenn man zweimal wirklich geblendet dann
wäre es noch viel ungefährdeter gewesen
so muss man sich wirklich schon film
investieren für kraft für energie aber
ich denke trotzdem hoch verdient
baumgartlinger ist es dann der in der 51
minute den ball zum 3 2 siegestor köpft
nizzas trainer patrick viera wird nach
dem spiel entlassen für leverkusen geht
es um den gruppensieg am donnerstag
gegen slavia prag vier tage nach dem
vertrauensvotum der dfb-spitze für
joachim löw hat dfb direktor oliver
bierhoff heute die arbeit des
bundestrainers energisch verteidigt er
sagte wörtlich ein tolles ergebnis dass
er unter den schweren bedingungen in
diesem jahr erreicht habe trotz der
spanien- niederlage
entscheidend sei jetzt die kommende em
wir bleiben dabei
jogi löw hat einen vertrag bis ende 22
aber natürlich ist es so dass die em 21
ein weiterer ein weiterer punkt ist in
dem man wieder schauen wird wie die
arbeit zu bewerten ist erstes freies
training in der formel 1 zum vorletzten
saisonrennen in bachrain ohne den an
corona erkrankten weltmeister lewis
hamilton sein ersatzmann george russell
wurde vom williams-team ausgeliehen und
der junge brite der vor gleich die
bestzeit in hamiltons mercedes vor den
red bull piloten verstappen und albern
sebastian vettel im ferrari wurde achter
das was vor mir und jetzt noch eine
kleine weihnachtsgeschichte weit weg in
down under ein koala sitzt im
weihnachtsbaum einer australischen
familie so ruhig dass in die für ein
plüschtier hält bis er anfängt nadeln zu
naschen ein fall für den quartetten
dienst der hat mühe
kleinen eindringlingen aus den essen zu
pflücken denn es gefällt ihm dort im
vorgarten wird er dann entlassen direkt
in einen eukalyptus baum mit
vielseitigeren blättern herbert regen
schnee und glätte in der nacht wo es
morgen schneit erfahren sie gleich beim
wetter von ist intelli so viel von uns
mehr gibt es im heute journal mit claus
kleber punkt sehen wir danken für ihre
aufmerksamkeit wünschen einen
entspannten freitagabend und sind morgen
wieder zur stelle um 71
[Musik]
ein kunde und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter dieser tief komplex hier der
bewegt sich kaum vom fleck und lenkt auf
die alpensüdseite große schneemengen
schweiz österreich und norditalien
bekommen große mengen ab zwei bis drei
meter neuschnee
an diesem wochenende sind durchaus drin
das ist enorm
bei uns kommt auch etwas schnee auf aber
nicht ganz so viel in der nacht im süden
und im südwesten schnee vor allem in den
höheren lagen das kann auch mal bis nach
unten schneiden und für schneeglätte
sorgen auch in den mittelgebirgen nach
norden ist hier schnee dabei ja heute im
nordwesten regnet es nach osten hin eher
trockenes wetter dort im vogtland bis -3
grad kalte 3 grad im westen deutschlands
hier leichte plusgrade morgen an den
alpen tagsüber schneefall in tiefen
lagen kann auch regen dabei sein
regen und schnee hier in den
mittelgebirgen und im westen das lässt
tagesverlauf nach im osten zeigt sich
sogar die sonne dort bleibt es trocken
und die temperaturen erreichen
höchstwerte
nach osten hin um 11 grad an den alpen
ein grad ja und die nächsten tage am
sonntag weitere schneefälle vor allem im
süden und im nordwesten auch regen dabei
null bis elf grad und danach allmählich
trockener ein schöner abend